thank you
everyone here dreads operation one bushu
which means take back in the local
language it's a security Crackdown that
the French government says is aimed at
expelling migrants and combating crime
tensions have been brewing since the
operation began in April
it's divided the local community and
those who have migrated from other
islands like comoros
I have been working since 2001 and never
stopped working I'm among the hottest
working women in this world to raise
seven children I work and save and today
they are kicking me out
there has also been a long-standing
debate over the status of the island
which is part of the comoros archipelago
but it is a French administrative
territory
gained independence from France in 1975
but mayot voted to stay in France
thousands of Islanders moves to my yacht
in search of better living standards and
as a way to get to France
we have nowhere to go because everything
we have is being dismantled the sheets
will be left in the field
the children the family we will find the
Terrace to sleep until sunrise we are
given a house but it's on the other side
of the island it is better that I stay
here
some human rights groups have accused
the government of using excessive force
on the residence
I think in the next week or two we
should do a new Zone we have a rhythm
five weeks after the order is issued we
have to clear the disputes so that's
about it next week or the next a new
operation
of My Yacht 350
000 residents half do not have French
nationality
France wants to deport them to comoros
but the government there has refused to
take them in so they have no jobs and
dozens of children have been separated
from their parents many have been made
homeless but they all say My Yacht is
still their home Catherine soy Al
Jazeera